python 3.11 is coming out very soon init
C python claim to be 10 to 60 percent
faster how did you pull that off and
what's C python C python is the last
python implementation standing also the
first one that was ever created the
original python implementation that I
started over 30 years ago so what does
it mean that python the programming
language is implemented in another
programming language called C what kind
of audience do you have in mind here
people who know programming no there's
somebody on a boat that's into fishing
and have never heard about programming
but also some world-class programmers
you're gonna have to speak to both
imagine a boat with two people one of
them has not heard about programming is
really into phishing and the other one
is like uh an incredible Silicon Valley
programmer that's programmed in
everything C C plus plus python rust
Java it knows the entire history of
programming languages so you're gonna
have to speak to both
I imagine that boat in the middle of the
ocean yes I'm gonna please the guy who
knows how to fish first yes please
he seems like the most useful in the
middle of the ocean you got you gotta
make him mad I'm sure he has a cell
phone so uh he's probably very
suspicious about what goes on in that
cell phone but he must have heard that
inside his cell phone is a tiny computer
and a programming language is computer
code that tells the computer what to do
it's a very low level
language it's zeros and ones and then
there's assembly and then oh yeah we
don't talk about these really low levels
because those just confuse people I mean
when we're talking about human language
we're not usually talking about vocal
tracts and how you position your tongue
I was talking yesterday about how when
you have a Chinese person and they speak
English uh this is this is a bit of a
stereotype they often don't know okay
they can't can't seem to make the
difference well between an l and an r
and I have a theory about that and I've
never checked this with linguists
uh that it probably has to do with the
fact that in Chinese there is not really
a difference and it could be that there
are Regional variations in how China
native Chinese speakers pronounce that
one sound that sounds to L to some like
L to some of them like R to others so
it's both the sounds you produce with
your mouth throughout the history of
your life and what you're used to
listening to I mean every language has
that Russian has exactly the Slavic
languages have sounds like the letters
like uh Americans or English speakers
don't seem to know the sounds
they seem uncomfortable with that sound
yeah so I'm sure oh yes okay so we're
not we're not going to the shapes of
tongues and the sounds that the mouth
can make fine words similarly we're not
going into the ones and zeros or machine
language I would say a programming
language is a list of instructions like
a cookbook recipe
that sort of tells you how to do a
certain thing like make a sandwich well
acquire a loaf of bread cut it in slices
take two slices put mustard on one put
the jelly on the other or something then
add the meat then add the cheese
I've heard that science teachers can
actually uh do great stuff with recipes
like that and trying to interpret their
students instructions incorrectly until
the students are completely unambiguous
about it
with language see that's the difference
between natural languages and
programming languages I think ambiguity
is a feature not a bug in human spoken
languages like uh
that's the dance of communication
between humans
well for lawyers ambiguity certainly is
a feature
uh for plenty of other cases uh the
ambiguity is is not much of a feature
but we work around it of course well
what's more important is context
so with context the Precision of the
statement becomes more and more concrete
right but you know when you say I love
you to a person that matters a lot to
you the person doesn't try to compile
that statement and return an error
saying please define love
right no but I imagine that my wife and
my son uh interpreted very differently
yes even though it's the same three
words but imprecisely still
oh for sure
lawyers never had a lot of follow-up
questions for you nevertheless the
context is already different different
in that case yes fair enough so that's
that's a programming language is uh
ability to unambiguously State a recipe
actually let's go back let's go to Pepe
you go through and pepe the style guide
for python code some ideas of what this
language should look like
feel like read like and the big idea
there is that code readability counts
what does that mean to you and how do we
achieve it so this recipe should be
readable that's a thing between
programmers
because on the one hand we always
explain the concept of programming
language as computers need instructions
and computers are very dumb and they
need very precise instructions because
they don't have much context in in fact
they have lots of context but their
their context is very different
but what we've seen emerge during the
development of software starting in the
probably in the late 40s
is that software is a very social
activity a software developer is not a
mad scientist who sits alone in his lab
writing brilliant code
software is developed by teams of people
uh even the Mad scientists sitting alone
in his lab can type fast enough to
produce enough code so that by the time
he's done with his coding he still
remembers what the first few lines he
wrote mean so even the mad scientist
coding alone in his lab would would be
sort of wise to
adopt conventions on how to format
the instructions that he gives to the
computer so that the thing is there is a
difference between a cookbook recipe and
a computer program
The cookbook recipe the the author of
The cookbook writes it once
and then it's printed in 100 000 copies
and then lots of people in their
kitchens try to recreate that recipe
that that that particular
pie or dish from the recipe and so there
the
the goal of the cookbook author is to
make it clear
to the human reader of the recipe the
human amateur Chef in most cases
when you're writing a computer program
you have two audiences at once
it needs to
tell the computer what to do
but it also is useful if that program is
readable by other programmers
because computer software unlike the
typical recipe for a cherry pie is so
complex
that you don't get all of it right at
once
you end up with the activity of
debugging and you end up with the
activity of so debugging is
trying to figure out why your code
doesn't run the way you thought it
should run that means brother could be
stupid little errors or it could be big
logical errors it could be anything
spiritual yeah it could be anything from
a typo to uh a wrong choice of algorithm
to
building something that does what you
tell it to do but that's not useful
yeah it seems to work really well 99 of
the time but does weird things one
percent of the time on some edge cases
that's pretty much all software nowadays
all good software right well yeah for
for bad software that that 99 goes down
a lot so but it's not just about the
complexity of the program it's like you
said it is a social endeavor
in that you're constantly improving that
recipe for the cherry pie but you're
sort of you're in a group of people
improving that recipe or the mad
scientist is improving the recipe that
he created a year ago and making it
better
or adding adding something he decides
that he wants a I don't know he wants
some decoration on his pie or icing or
so there's broad philosophical things
and there's specific advice on Style
so first of all the thing that people
first experience when they look up
python
there is a it is very readable
but there's also like a spatial
structure to it
can you explain the indentation style of
python and what is the magic to it space
cases are important for readability of
any kind of text
if you take a cookbook recipe
and you remove all the sort of
all the bullets and other markup
and you just crunch all the text
together maybe you leave the spaces
between the words but that's all you
leave
when you're in the kitchen trying to
figure out oh what are the ingredients
and what are the steps
and where does this step end and the
next step begin you're going to have a
hard time if it's if it's just one solid
block of text
on the other hand what what a typical
cookbook does if the paper is not too
expensive
each recipe starts on its own page maybe
there's a picture next to it the list of
ingredients comes first
uh there's a standard notation the
there's there's shortcuts so that you
don't have to sort of write two
sentences on how you have to cut the
onion because there are only three ways
that people ever cut onions in a kitchen
small medium and in slices or something
like that
right none of my examples make any sense
to real Cooks of course but yeah
we're talking to programmers with a
metaphor of cooking I love it
um but there is a strictness to the
spacing that python defines so there's
some
a looser thing some stricter things but
the four spaces for the
for the indentation is really
interesting it it really um it really
defines what the language looks and
feels like because indentation sort of
taking a block of text and then having
inside that block of text
a smaller block of text that is indented
further as sort of a group it's it's
it's like you have an A bulleted list
in a complex business document and
inside some of the bullets are other
bulleted lists you will indent those too
if each bulleted list is indented
several inches then at two levels deep
there's no no space left on the page to
put any of the words of the text so you
can't indent too far on the other hand
if you don't indent at all you can tell
whether something is a top level bullet
or a second level bullet or a third
level bullet so you have to have
some compromise and uh based on Ancient
conventions
and the sort of the typical width of a
computer screen in the 80s
uh and all sorts of things sort of
we we came up with sort of four spaces
as a compromise I mean there there are
groups there are large groups of people
who code with uh two spaces per indent
level for example the Google style guide
uh all the Google python code and I
think also all the Google C plus plus
code is indented with only two spaces
per block if you're not used to that
it's harder to at a glance
understand the code because the the sort
of the the high level structure is
determined by the indentation on the
other hand there are there are other
programming languages where the
indentation is uh eight spaces or a
whole tab stop in in sort of classic
Unix and to me that looks weird because
you you sort of have to free indent
levels you've you've got no room left
well there's some languages where the
indentation is a recommendation
it's a stylistic one the code compiles
even without any indentation
and then python really indentations a
fundamental part of the language right
it doesn't have to be four spaces so you
you can code python with two spaces per
block or or six Paces or 12 if you
really want to go wild but
sort of everything
that belongs to the same block needs to
be indented the same way
in practice in most other languages
people recommend doing that anyway if
you look at
C or rust or C plus plus
all those languages Java don't have a
requirement of indentation
but except in extreme cases
they're just as anal about having their
code properly indented so any IDE that
the syntax highlighting that works with
Java or C plus they will yell at you
aggressively if you don't do proper
indentation they'd suggests the proper
indentation for you like uh in C you
type a few words and then you type a
curly brace which there is their notion
of sort of begin and an indented block
uh then you hit return and then it
automatically indents four or eight
spaces depending on uh your your style
preferences or how your editor is
configured was there a possible Universe
in which you considered having braces in
Python absolutely yeah well there's a 60
40 70 30 in your head uh uh what was the
trade-off for a long time I was actually
convinced that the indentation was just
better
uh
without context I would still claim that
indentation is better
uh it reduces clutter however as I
started to say earlier context is almost
everything
and in the context of coding
most programmers are familiar with
multiple languages even if they're only
good at one or two and apart from Python
and maybe Fortran I don't know how
that's written these days anymore but
all the other languages Java rust CC
plus plus JavaScript typescript Perl are
all using curly braces uh to sort of
indicate blocks and so python is the odd
one out
just a radical idea do you still as a
radical Renegade revolutionary do you
still stand behind this idea of space of
uh indentation versus braces
like what what can you dig into it a
little bit more
why you still stand behind indentation
because context is not the whole story
history in in a sense provides more
context so for python
there's no chance that we can switch
python is using curly braces for
something else dictionaries mostly
we would get in trouble if we wanted to
switch just like you couldn't redefine C
to use indentation even if you agree
that it that indentation sort of
in a Greenfield environment would be
better
you can't change that kind of thing in a
language yeah it's hard enough to reach
agreement over over much more Minor
Details maybe I mean in the past in
Python we did have a big debate about
test versus spaces and four spaces
versus fewer or more
and we sort of came up with
a recommended standard and sort of
options for people who want to be
different
but yes I guess the thought experiment
I'd like you to consider is if you could
travel back through time when the when
the compatibility is not an issue and he
started python all over again
can you make the case for uh indentation
still
well it frees up a pair of
matched brackets of which there are
never enough in the world
uh for other purposes really makes the
language slightly
sort of
easier to grasp for people who don't
already know
another programming language
because the sort of one of the things
and I I mostly got this from my mentors
who were
taught me programming language design in
the earlier 80s when you're teaching
programming
for for the the total newbie who has not
coded before in not in any other
language
uh a whole bunch of Concepts in
programming are very alien or
sort of
new and and maybe very interesting but
also distracting and confusing and there
are many different things you have to
learn you have to sort of
in a typical
13-week programming course you have to
if it's like really
learning to program from scratch you
have to cover algorithms you have to
cover data structures you have to cover
syntax you have to cover variables Loops
functions recursion classes
Expressions operators there are so many
Concepts if you you sort of
if you can spend a little less time
having to worry about the syntax
the the classic example was often
oh the compiler complains every time I
put a semicolon in the wrong place or I
forget to put a semicolon
uh python doesn't have semicolons in
that sense so you can't forget them and
you're also not
sort of misled into putting them where
they don't belong because you don't
learn about them in the first place
the flip side of that is forcing the
strictness onto the beginning programmer
to teach them that programming is a
values attention to details you don't
get to just write the way you write in
English you have other details that they
have to pay attention to so I think
they'll they'll still get the message
about uh
paying attention to detail